la première grande race rats je vous le
dis c'est c'est donc maxime gainey et
gilles verdez qui sont partis pour une
caméra cachée je vous explique ya trois
mois on a fait croire à gilles et maxime
qu'on les a menés en tunisie avant tout
le monde pour tourner le prochain prime
sauf qu'une fois sur place on leur a
fait faire des dosses improbable il
était persuadé que c'était vraiment le
voyage en tunisie alors que pas du tout
son parti dans la journée sont venues le
soir c'est le manque de hmam la séquence
du massage à mon avis je vous le dis on
va se la revoir en est un très très
grand moment et bien sûr dans un instant
je donnerais d'autres numéros et tous à
la fota castaldi regardez c'est parti
jeux de rang
[Applaudissements]
question de plaisir détracteurs mon
maquillage et bien m'occuper de toi tu
as confiance en moi non chez nous c'est
la vidéo du patron quand qu'on salue les
séries bah je suis content de vous voir
mais aussi avec dans quelques minutes ça
va être le démarre dans la tunisie 34° à
louvres le kit babouche makrouds les
chéris j'espère vous n'avez pas donné
d'affaires car j'ai tout prévu pour vous
allez bon vous allez vous habiller
locale vous avez cinq minutes pour aller
dans les toilettes allez-vous changer c
moi qui régale
faites vous plaisir cinq minutes cinq
minutes un top chrono
legault au tennis
oui mais c'est là
[Musique]
caf on a plus que jamais regarde et où
tu pars ça sent bon assez là bas je
croirais s'il allait bien aller mon max
j'ai déjà hâte d'être au tennis c'est
chaud là oui plus que jamais j'ai un
petit musée rend l'âme
[Musique]
très bien 1 fasse pas dans des eaux et
ouais on est bien parti je dois ça y est
on y est on est en tunisie les cherry et
je suis encore là alors les chéris
première étape très importante vous
allez devoir aller chez ma tata tata m
tata mêlera lm un truc c'est la route
leur route vous allez le trouver dans un
marché de tunisie vous allez devoir
ramer dur ou tchadors matin mêlera bien
sûr sont une sans mauvais routage de
rôti euros pour acheter du route au
marché à l'oeil on en marche et acheter
du route acheter du groupe au marché
toujours marché tunis re souk
complètement malade tu les effraie les
effraie le sur base des seuils toit
arrière âgé c'est la subtilité puisque
pour l'instant que bon alors
voilà c'est vrai bonjour de route vous
marchez tennis et les mules benghazi
vers l'asie shalom salam aleikoum on va
en tout cas pour marcher à l'évidence
vite les deux des quatre enfants l'homme
au charme
ce que je comprends à raison s'ils sont
là c'est un bon jour pourquoi est-ce
qu'ils sortent samedi comme ça pourquoi
bravo sofa est formidable
les maxi bien et avoue que j'étais d'un
soutien indéniable dans la voiture de
son père mais là s'il vous faut des
routes attendu toute attente en mai bien
trompé de route pour ta tamera s'est
loupé du route
il nous faut lire aux beaux-arts est ce
que je vais vous faire un tour de magie
à l'aller et le pousse à aller des 1
laisse tomber matches nuls ton tour
vient
bonjour monsieur bonjour monsieur et on
cherche de route du rhum apatam et
l'ipad mais rappellera aux ja oui
incroyable exploit tamera merci monsieur
monsieur allait bien bien aller route
bravo les chiffres vous êtes formidables
vous êtes au top du top
maintenant vous allez trouver du route
va falloir nous avons toujours beaucoup
en retour qui va vous amener à matha
mettra beaucoup de monde sourit d où
tous les après midi
il est au hammam et ouais c'est un
keeper suis là et au hammam qui
s'appelle le à mamir vous allez là-bas
vous allez demander un spécial bonjour
bonjour bozo et bonsoir oui c'est moi
alors s'il m'a dit devienne officiel est
allé tunisienne voilà d'accord va
changer là vous êtes chez vous d'un
mensonge
[Musique]
ce malaise vous allez vous asseoir la
juste à côté de ces villas d'or
[Musique]
il
oui
[Musique]
mais
on va faire ça
[Musique]
il faut bonjour bien la spécialité vas-y
gillet chez avec tout leur étoile et si
tu as besoin
n'hésite pas à crier
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
nous étions vous êtes masters
non
[Applaudissements]
oui
g
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors
oa
l'annoncé a mis à bas
c'est magnifique on y va vous avez vu la
qualité des tissus
les belges ou les importer des routes
que jamais tu t'es vue à te mettre la
wii comme ça il nous encadrent sur vous
même effet qu'un arrière la postule un
civet
elle a fait les galaxies un jour on
santé ça martine bon soir abel vous
connais revient bien et va très bien on
peut se tutoyer si vous voulez je t'en
fais elle sait tout faire
ah oui la pauvre il lui manque juste une
chose mais quoi ouais c'est les papiers
de papier n'est pas de pièces et puis
ben vise à l'ap un but mais pour les
pâtes il faut france marié quoi va se
marier
on va se marier
non avenches et saint lô il a raison les
mêmes portes mga portail à iamal et les
des maximes belvédère à mieux pour
manger voilà montre lui biard tu as une
copine ça peut compliquer en ce moment
les arrête
je m'entraîne tenir le mystère sosa n'a
pu aller au bout mais c'est hyper et du
c'est un mélange et apam c'est pas
possible je mange de la même assiette
que vous êtes vous
tenez monsieur verrait bien merci
comment t'as fait mais c'est d'être en
2000 où elle adore le même palais que
nous on mange ta vu maladie dont la vie
n'est pas possible elle la respire après
on va les prendre l'air respiré temps
avec les enfants et tous avec blatgé
merci seigneur mais aux bizots un hasard
si pour toi bientôt à ses yeux la donne
les passes et les papiers
[Musique]
fulla maximum à l'ère open mais qu'est
ce que c'est que ce bordel
alors qu'est-ce qui se passe boc de
petit coquin tu en as fait c'est quoi
votre plan le félin gérer en taxi bravo
les chéris vous êtes des premiers les
grands vainqueurs c'est vous qui avez
gagné ce magnifique périment à gagner
mais juste un truc parce que vous n'avez
pas compris c'est que prennent pour la
tunisie en fait si on joue on ne sait
pas du tout maintenant donc je crois
tout ce que vous avez fait là c'était
juste parce que j'avais envie de revoir
ta caméra est juste tout d'abord un
petit coupé poisson bienvenue dans la
grande race track à chaque fois tu nous
fais chier barbara [ __ ] à chaque fois
c'est pas possible
maxime